[Music]
hi I'm Jake Lussier I'm the product lead
for the flying car now in degree and I'm
joined today by one of our lead
instructors professor Raffaello Dandrea
thank you very much for joining us
thanks for having me so we're super
excited today to introduce our
curriculum and talk a little bit about
it and get ref's take on it so really
this curriculum is divided into two
terms and the first term is going to be
about aerial robotics and then the
second term is going to be what we're
referring to as intelligent air systems
so this is going to go a bit more into
flying cars specifically in fixed-wing
flight as well as whatever it what it
takes to design the entire system so as
the expert and one of the luminaries in
the field RAF I'd like to I guess first
get your take on the first term so the
first term is aerial robotics in which
we'll be covering planning control and
estimation if you could kind of talk
about why those are really important
skills in this world yes so I mean the
first thing you have to do with
something that that flies is you know
get it to at least hover right and that
requires a lot of knowledge just to
being able to do that and that's you
know there's the control part there's
the estimation part which is taking all
the sensed information and give you the
situational awareness that you need in
order to be able to fly but once you
once you're once you can do that you
know once you can make this thing hover
and move from point A to point B well
then you want to achieve a mission with
that so it's then you need to build the
competency above that level that says
okay how do i navigate in this
environment do i go to the left to what
I go to the right there's an obstacle
that popped in my way how do I get out
of its way how do I achieve my
objectives so that's really kind of what
the first term is about it's you know
doing those three different things and
they all obviously interrelate and I
think it's going to be really exciting
the way the the way that the students
learn these two things too and that
they'll get to implemented right there
in the browser they'll immediately get
feedback on these things that we're
in this environment that allows for
rapid prototyping and they'll work
towards a project where they'll
implement code in C++ that they can then
if they want port it to a real drone and
have something flying around
autonomously in their home which i think
is like really that magic that you've
built a career around and we really hope
to give that to students yeah I mean I
think it's one of the even with just a
you know a little mobile robot it's very
cool to programming it and you know have
it do something it's extra magical when
you can actually make it fly just
because flying is seems like such a
magical thing it's something that we
cannot do physically right but we can
certainly locomote but flying is just
it's an ability that we don't have so
when we see something that we create fly
it's you know it gives you this
incredible you know sense of
accomplishment and creation I also think
that the you develop some very
interesting skill sets when you do
things with flight because unlike a
mobile robot that you know if it breaks
down or does something silly
you know worst case you kill the program
and it stops with a flying machine you
know if something wrong happens if you
do something silly it's gonna crash and
break so you know you have you have to
learn how to design simple things in a
in a in a way that ensures that
minimizes the probability that bad
things are gonna happen and and these
are the kind of things that we try to
expose the students in the first part of
the course you know how to properly use
simulation environments how to have
different types of simulation
environments depending on the objective
that you're trying to achieve so this
this methodology of designing things
that have certain levels of of
performance that you can guarantee
certain levels of reliability that's a
that's not just going to be useful for
for autonomous drones or flying cars
it's gonna be important for any sort of
multi agent autonomous autonomous system
and I guess as we're talking about
autonomous systems that that brings us
to the second term where we are really
looking at both flying cars and about
entire systems of aerial vehicles so
specifically what the students will be
learning then they'll get an
introduction
into fixed-wing flight in a bit of
vehicle design and then they'll learn
about adaptation omits flight via system
identification and calibration and then
from there we'll go to mission
optimization and fleet coordination so
can you
those are those are kind of a lot of
words yeah can you maybe break it down
and talk about the importance of the
second term right you know the first
term I mean there's many ways to break
it down the first term is really just to
get one vehicle to do something
interesting from the very low level of
just taking off and landing to being
able to go from point A to point B and
then there's the other extreme of okay
you can do all that stuff now how do you
manage hundreds of thousands of these
things how do you architect the airspace
so that you can make the problem
tractable so that you can make it
distributed so those are the extremes
and kind of work our way up to doing
that you know in the second term we also
look at things like you know fixed-wing
aircraft fixed-wing dynamics and that's
because that's gonna be a key component
to flying cars is efficient flight and
multi rotor vehicles such as a quad are
very maneuverable they're mechanically
simple which means that they tend to be
reliable and rules there's a lot of
things going for it
but if you want to be efficient you need
to augment multi rotor flight with some
sort of fixed fixed wing lifting
surfaces to give you that efficiency
that you need so we spend a little bit
of time talking about that and the other
part of course is the you know the the
calibration problem you want to use
inexpensive navigation units but have
you know the ability during flight to
learn about non idealities and
compensate for them and that's that's
really a calibration sort of stage it's
is to make these things economically
viable and also to make them robust and
you know calibration adaptation is a
very important important feature yeah
and I think as we as we get into these
topics of systems and safety I think
that's another big thing that we do
really want to emphasize
the course we want to as students are
developing their code solutions for real
drones we want to actually get into the
nitty-gritty of it and teach them about
common issues walk them through
debugging exercise teach them a bit
about architecture decisions so that as
this world evolved sil they'll not only
have those skills that are generally
applicable but hopefully be able to
apply them and be leaders in this
emerging and wildly changing world so I
think that's something that we really
want the course to shine on as well yeah
I think it's important to learn these
skills these skills are going to be
super important for any sort of
autonomous systems that is going to be
deployed you know it becomes I can
assess 'ti that you know in other realms
you know maybe could work around it but
here you have to you have to do it right
because these things are flying and
they're if they're gonna carry people
they have to be ultra safe and reliable
great well thanks so much and I think
we're both really excited about the
curriculum I think it has a lot to offer
for the students I think both aerial
robotics intelligent air systems and
really getting down coding these things
having the possibility to put it on
hardware and see you think fly this is
going to be a magical experience a
really educational experience and
something that is going to empower
students to actually go out and do real
things with these solutions too so
thanks so much Raph and thank you we
hope to see you in the classroom
[Music]